salut à tous alors aujourd'hui on est
sur les bords du canal du midi
pas loin d'un petit village voilà c'est
très joli très mignon des petits canards
derrière nous on va essayer de pêcher le
plus de choses possibles et on espère
que ça va bien se passer
on commence tout de suite avec la pêche
donc avec le petit chant des oiseaux
très très agréable en typhon bien sûr je
mets encore comme d'habitude une
demi-heure à des fermes à cordes et puis
quand on atteint directement avec son
amant beast il trouve à environ deux
fois plus de choses que moi mais mes
j'abandonne pas et j'essaie de lui
mettre à l'envers
ça il semblerait que ce soit des vieux
outils preview ça c'est peut-être non je
sais pas mais c'est en voie de faire ça
c'est bien épais on continue la garde
belle petite 3 une nouvelle clé ancien
ça je vais regarder je pense landed
comment ces enfants tu sais pas du tout
ce que c'est mais c'est un joli forme
très lourd regardez jamais vos trucs
le bidon
ce
cette barre à mine deviennent des
journées déjà
[Musique]
un kilo pour compte
sortez un senior et une barre de fer
tous a annoncé sans bouger les mains à
la barre alors vieilles plaques
d'immatriculation ou encore quelques
numéros la la nettoyer c'est possible
que ça ressorte et bien
ici un pieu ben pas très gros mais assez
massif
ouais pas mal pour moi aussi c'est déjà
ça ouais
il est maintenu
matamec
la fourchette la fourchette bon ben je
pense qu'on mangera jamais avec tant pis
surtout qu'ils mentent et nous accrocher
à
puis en
bien parce qu'ils tentaient d'affronter
tous à fin décembre 16h
sa culture
que c'est en fait pour
ah oui
bon du coup là je pense qu'on a fait le
touriste il n'y a pas grand chose on va
essayer de s'approcher un peu plus du
port du petit village pour voir si ya
pas de travail un petit peu plus
original
[Musique]
alors ça c'est la trouvaille qui
accélérerait le coeur c'est le sac
poubelle au fond de l'eau voilà pour le
coup y avait rien du tout mais voilà
toujours bien vérifié à l'intérieur des
sacs poubelles des fois des jolies
surprises
[Musique]
là pour le coup c'est un outil très très
rouillée voit sa part à la ferraille
direct
[Musique]
m
à
une jolie pièce
placé des francs
qu'on a là on a la totale de la cuillère
kitano les petites capsules d'objets
difformes
pas sûr qu'ils marchent encore mais
attesté au revoir attendez je le mets la
clé
ah non aïe pas sûr qu il fonctionne
encore crois qu'il est tellement voyez
le truc êtes si j'enfonce la clé se
tourner et a peur de se fermer mais oui
mais oui elle est trop belle
25 centimes de francs 1905
sa sé li bo est en bon état
bonjour enfin
aucun 29
c'est parce que c'est
une bobine de kyo
un truc avec une bobine de cuivre petite
pelle cassé au bout je sais pas comment
ils ont fait ça mais l'ambiance
détruites
pourtant d'autres nous rattache
seulement on va dire qu'on peut toujours
servir mais on va mettre un ferry
alors là on a une boule de pétanque
c'est sûr c'est avéré qui on a ce truc
rond aussi qui a un petit by couleurs
qui est pas lourd donc c'est pas un
boulet de canon quoi est ce que ce
serait pas une grenade
c'est pas sûr c'est peut-être on va voir
niveau taille on va comparer avec les
photos qu'on a ce serait voilà une
vieille grenade peut-être vos la
première guerre ou quoi voit pas trop la
faire rouler on va la laisser un peu
tranquille mais ouais dans tous les cas
c'est pas une boule de pétanque
voilà bon on se retrouve pour les
trouvailles de la journée comme un petit
peu nettoyer bon excusez moi j'ai des
ongles noirs mais ça c'est la pêche
donc voilà 5 cuillères donc 5 hier par
jour c'est un bon ratio on pourra
bientôt une autre boutique de cuillère
elles sont toutes un peu un peu jolie à
leur façon c'est pas mal hop on a aussi
trouvé non ça danse ça c'est la saint
patrick
la up et de pièces donc première pièce
ici que de 25 centimes de francs 1905
donc voilà une pièce qu'on a trouvé à 40
euros sur ebay quand elle est en bon
état
donc voilà plutôt joli ensuite des fera
encore une fois ici donc deux francs
1982 un petit peu en moins bon état mais
met pas mal non plus aussi on la
trouvait aussi hop une jolie clé on vole
à créer des clés de château un très très
très très belle
une petite bobines de cuivre voilà bon
c'est pas grand chose mais bon 4 euros
le kilo de cuivre c'est déjà bien
ensuite des ciseaux donc des coupes
ongles très très joli ils sont
fonctionnels en plus un voilà je vais
les tester en direct pour vous public
hop voilà très très beau donc voilà je
pense qu'on va pouvoir en tirer un bon
prix au marché noir
ensuite un tournevis cruciforme donc
très beau lui aussi magnusson wild un
petit peu abîmés mais c'est pas grave
parce que regarder hop il est aimanté
donc on va pouvoir s'en servir pour la
pêche aux capsules
donc je pense qu'on va le de suite
accroché au bout d'une corde on a le ton
à la partie là qui était faite pour et
on testera sa n'hésitez pas en tout cas
à nous dire ce que vous pensez de nos
trouvailles en commentaire et à nous
suivre un petit peu on va essayer de
faire d'autres vidéos rapidement